[Music]
GRA in 2014 shadow of mordor introduced
the revolutionary nemesis system
millions of players forge their own
personal stories with unique enemies and
allies and now with the all new free
Nemesis forge update their stories will
continue in shadow of war launch shadow
of Mordor and select the Nemesis forge
game-mode if you've already played
shadow of Mordor at the Nemesis forge
will automatically detect your
highest-ranking orc nemesis if you're
new to the game you'll be facing your
own unique nemesis soon nemesis Forge
will also identify your most loyal orc
follower
we'll help you overthrow saurons forces
when the highly-anticipated shadow of
war releases on october 10th this year
your nemesis and follower will be
waiting for you missus porch available
only with the purchase of middle-earth
shadow of Mordor at Middle Earth shadow
before a Microsoft Xbox one Sony
PlayStation 4 or PC digital download and
subject at all times to the WB Terms of
Service nemesis forge is not available
in Japan